keep Gathering points as they're so important
right now especially for this Penguins team
where they're at's trying to push closer into
that playoff pack of the East conuts firmly
in trench sh West as Pon throws it to the net
they score back door feed to Brock besser is
26th of the Season gives Vancouver an early one-
nothing lead D Pon pulled the same move off his
last shift just ENT entering the zone as it's
besser touched by Miller through and then he
just drives that middle through look at that
play by Pon jumping to the inside head up and
it's really almost a little give and go with a
Miller touch in between as besser delivers it
from his own blue line and then just heads that
back door there's a great shot of him working
away from the puck to find it there he threw
it in off one and0 Victory against Philly on
Monday but the kucks come in up one nothing on
the first Power Play of the night for either
team qu Hughes takes the pass from Pon givs it
back to him Elias Pon across JT Miller shot to
flex in besser again besser sent that to the back
of the net a power play goal for Vancouver in an
early two nothing lead for the Canucks they made
short work here once they get in and get set up
they get it to Hughes Hughes is the guy and he
starts rolling across and shaping this penalty
kill box and Miller likes to pop up top and roll
downhill and we know he can shoot the puck he's
got a lethal shot takes a little off and just
looks for that high tip stick right there with
traffic in front delovic no chance on that
high tip Carlson takes it back to Malin again
to Carlson and Genny Malin for Eric Carlson
Crosby snapshot save up go rebound put wide
by Malin a show for it but almost right here just
wouldn't lay flat for 71 it's Pon banking it ahead
for Carter tips it to the neutral zone Harkins
he can move as well picks up the puck hands it
off to Carter stick check bouncing cck Harkins
tracks it down good work back for Pon a shot
score great work from Jansen Harkins and
a finish from Marcus Pon his first of the
year as it 2-1 Vancouver what a play by Jansen
Harkin all around right here just a dog on this
Puck but then ability Under Pressure to make the
next play we talk about Dr Conor being like that
Parkins game to another level here he's got
that work ethic as You' see it come through
with a good screen from a chart you got to get
well Todd he doesn't need your ride to the rink
today did it on his own you'll be good to you'll
be happy to hear off the draw gel shot is kicked
out by Demco been awesome to see how he gets
more comfortable to his game right you can send
confidence absolutely you can see it there's
JT Miller twisting and turning back for Philip
heric his Snapper scores another deflection
Alias Pon may have gotten stick on Puck and
Vancouver goes back up two here in the first
last six games he's on absolute fire you see
they work it down low JT Miller just kicks out
from behind the one side of the net all the way
around and relieves all that pressure to ronic
who's seventh in the NHL and defenseman scoring
to go with his partner out there Quin Hughes
who's first and just a traffic and shot from the
point putting some points together here in the
last three games or so 26 points over the last
10 periods centering pass in front and jar a
good stop here early on Dakota Joshua tracks
that right in there and he had to be ready by
coming in in relief there's the first save on
to Eric Carlson knocked off his stick Garland
in front wer shot glove save jar look what he's
got all Teddy Bluer X teammate just snags it
out of the air look at this just confidently
watches it right into his glove saw him take
the hit from theik Zadora back in the first
he did return but not not available at the
moment kmo twisting and turning a jar his
third excellent stop in the first two minutes
of this second period the man in Black and
the lady in red oh there you go and here we go
Sydney Crosby with Rael Here Comes Crosby shot
score move over Mike bossy Sydney Crosby now
tied for 22 all time in NHL history another
one pass another great pass great play by gentel
on the wall right there just a little touch play
and Josh I'm telling you I saw Crosby at practice
the other day he was out there at the end working
on this shot coming around out of the corner
but shooting right from that point right there
that let keeping track he went five for seven on
that four game point streak and he comes a shot
to flex wide rust good work picks up the puck
across a shot from Carlson off the post taken
away by Vancouver as Pon has stick knocked out of
his hands Canucks come in Myers Hing shooting oh
Tristan jari putting on a show coming in in relief
look at this jari top of his crease watches it
right into that glove H comes back to Susi it's
spinning like a top as the Penguins unable to
come up with it tesser tumbles to the ice Pon
there here he comes elas Pon behind and at the
wraparound is stopped by jari Jar's off for the
extra skater that's Malin he takes the puck Here
Comes Malin SS away from TR Crosby in front save
demo he missed it earlier Penguins down a forward
no Riley Smith as the tank tackled at Center by
JT Miller on we go shot off the post from besser
there's a turnover by Vancouver Jake gensel going
to check it on the score sheet Crosby backhander
oh Deco oh my God what a stop got him for holding
as we look at this chance great four check and it
ends up great on the stick of Crosby you can see
it reached out there what a great look of it now
right back in across here's Jeff Carter he'll put
it to the net loose save by De he got a piece of
the poost the chance laying down doing anything
to get that puck out of there face off win here's
Carlson Riser the flex in they score the Penguins
TI It Crosby was there and he's pull Pittsburgh
even and Mr Hart Trophy how do you not think
anything else is right there at the net front
after the draw and just hits off his leg I used
to make fun of him all the time for his size of
his back end and his size of those legs well they
come in handy for a lot of things might have had
L Tang there quickly as they were crossing the
blue line here comes jakay kensler he's got to
step on Miller gets a backand save made by
Deno especially the penguins at the luxury
of having been a couple bullies that can
play the puck here come the pens off the
turnover Carlson charging in centering
it's knocked down and Vancouver's got a
break Alias pson he's gone on goal ji makes
the save and it trickles through Pon wins it
for Vancouver in overtime 43 the final this
is the chance as they came in and and Carlson
just looking to shot pass to that back door
and that was broke up and left Pon in alone I
thought Crosby just pestered him enough on
the back check defensively Pon with a hot
stick nine goals in his last six games played
with the overtime winner nine goals in six
games just eeks through Tristan jari the
extra points to Vancouver what a battle